-Guys, as I said earlier
everyone is talking about this
new COVID variant Omicron.
We don't know much about it yet,
so I thought it would be helpful
to break down
what's real and what's not.
It's time for "Fact Versus
Fiction," here we go.
-♪ Fact ♪
♪ Fact versus fiction ♪
-Let's get started.
First up, fact,
the variant is called Omicron.
Fiction,
Omicron is also the name
of a villain in the new
Spider-Man movie.
[ Applause ]
That's fake, that's not true.
-Not true.
-Here's another one.
Fact, New York City has issued
a health advisory.
Fiction, because they saw
someone actually eating
from a "Nuts 4 Nuts" cart.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait.
-Next -- that's not true.
-That's not true,
that's fiction.
-Next, fact, Biden says
there's no need to panic.
Fiction, but he said you are
allowed to freak out about
Netflix dropping the entire new
season of "Selling Sunset."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, the whole --
after that, we have fact.
The variant is
also known as B.1.1.529.
Fiction, not to be confused with
your parent's wi-fi password,
which is 1234567!
Don't forget
the exclamation point,
that's what makes it different.
[ Laughter ]
-No one will ever guess.
-No one, yeah.
Finally, fact, Omicron is most
likely already in the U.S.,
but hasn't been detected yet.
Fiction, people think it's the
skunk on "The Masked Singer."
Wow, that's all the time we have
for "Fact Versus Fiction."